it's the sort of invitation you wait a
lifetime to receive come to the Mojave
we're camping out next to the trona
pinnacles they're weird and beautiful
sense
there will be beers and burgers and
tequila and a bunch of gearheads and
techno freaks hanging out together
we're going to show you how we're
reinventing cars he says and we're gonna
go spine crushing fast
this is Mouse McCoy is a sort of hotrod
Renaissance man with a vision on where
the cars of tomorrow are designed by
artificial intelligence right now we're
in the space where like this stuff
seemed like science fiction but it's
actually science fact like we're living
science fact right before our eyes and
to be a part of it
this feels feels good though Mouse's
latest venture is called hacker ID the
goal is to blend human emotion and
technology to spur an automotive
revolution to do this Mouse and his team
measure everything they can they wire up
cars with dozens of sensors to see how
the metal performs then they create 3d
maps of their racing courses to figure
out exactly how the car behaves and on
top of all that they strap brainwave
monitors on their heads to detect stress
I think it's safe to say that as I strap
in for today's test I'm showing signs of
anxiety already hopefully we'll see pure
panic in the brain on it
the hotrod team doesn't start with an
off-the-shelf car chassis
they use artificial intelligence
software to come up with designs and
fabricate them on a 3d printer design
software and new manufacturing
techniques have gotten good enough to
allow a small group of people to build
custom cars from scratch we're getting
in this mass world where just design
decisions are dictated your aesthetic is
dictated by some corporate strategy
somewhere and it's like that was that
hot rodder you know sort of thing and a
lot of our mission here is going to be
about individualization like having your
own design having your own vehicle this
is a full car felix holes used to
oversee the Hot Wheels and matchbox
brands from Mattel he's a car junkie who
quit the Mattel gig to start hacker out
with Mouse we think this may be the
first shutter that's been engineered
with artificial intelligence that AI
sucks up data collected from the desert
field tests felix gives it a few
guidelines and it spits out a body
design you test it feed the data back in
and get an even better car out what used
to take years and hundreds of engineers
can now be done in a matter of months or
so hacker ID hopes to prove we both come
from a kind of hotrod culture the hacker
culture and we looked at this as like
look we're not Ford or Ferrari or
whoever we don't have hundreds and
hundreds of Engineers to start designing
a chassis from the ground up and there's
a real democratization of creativity and
design going on that we that we don't we
stand for
this car is called the mule it was the
first built using hack rod technology
and it's been utterly abused by mouse
over the course of three days soon we
time to head back to LA and let the
computers do their work to replace it
with mule 2.0
what's your vision for where this
company is in like five years in five
years I think we will have been a
significant driver in the automatic
manufacturing world that's coming